[Music]
in India poverty is so pervasive
that you can either decide to forget
about it or you can decide to fight it
you can't ignore it
India has the world's largest child
population
more than 150 million children in the
age group of zero to six years of age
live in India 50 of them go to the free
government system
however if you look at grade 5 and
learning outcomes we find that nearly
half of the kids in India are unable to
read a single paragraph or to do basic
subtraction or division which renders
them unable to do anything for their
informal education or even formal
employment
my goal as a social entrepreneur is to
come up with Solutions and innovations
that really change the fabric of the
world in a way that benefits low income
population and population that nobody is
building anything for essentially we're
trying to change the social fabric of
the country and the Norms of the country
no situation where low income parents
who are majority of the population are
actually going to spend time every day
20 minutes on learning this is a huge
change right you're trying to basically
shift time use patterns of a huge
population onto something that they have
not been doing earlier and so I think
that challenge is what consumes us every
day
[Music]
so I was born to a family of government
officials we lived in smaller parts of
India as well and we could see the
poverty and the lack of opportunities
that others faced but I was lucky that I
was in a middle class family and got the
best out of Education I think from early
age we were cognizant of the privilege
that we've had in terms of great
education the opportunities that that
afforded us and on the flip side the
lack of opportunity that faces more than
five crore or 50 million children today
in the 0 to 6 age group in the country
the more I thought about it and the more
over the last 10 years as I've worked in
the social impact space I felt that the
first six years are where most of your
development happens of your brain and
your body
we're an edtech non-profit working to
help one million children in India so
far with early childhood education
our short-term goal at Rocket learning
is to really comprehensively work
together to help children get up to
speed
rocket learning's approach is to create
these Dynamic digital communities of
parents and preschool teachers to
empower them and Inspire them to be
active participants and enablers in
their child's learning so rocket
learning has created 70 000 WhatsApp
groups which act as Dynamic communities
on which we are able to share some
content that is easy for children to do
in their own homes or in their Learning
Centers you already are on WhatsApp
you're already using it to send messages
to your family etc etc and so through
that 70 000 groups and one million
parents get our content we're able to
then send back nudges and content it's
very personalized for a particular user
a particular group particularly teacher
we have more than 2 000 audiovisual
pieces worksheets etc etc that are then
shared with the Last Mile with parents
and teachers who can then use them in
their daily life
[Music]
the railways are shut the airlines will
soon be shot and Interstate bus travel
is all shut there's a lot of unknowns
about how this is going to play out in
India and the honest truth is nobody
really knows at this point
for close to two years in India and in
fact in the world children did not come
to schools so more schooling actually
shifted to homeschooling for those two
years and so maybe the higher income
child didn't lose out on so much they
also had access to online classes and so
on but low-income children living in
rural parts of the world were not able
to access any sort of online education
for the most part that's where our
programs for engaging parents through
technology actually came into being it's
not rocket science honestly to teach
kids the basic fundamentals you just
need to be able to give some information
to the right person one is parents of
children low income parents secondly we
saw that you know there are these 1.3
million body workers across the country
daycare workers paid by government all
female they feel that they can be
Educators and that they should be
recognized as such and they also feel
that they need support to do a better
job in their classrooms
over the last few years we've been lucky
to see phenomenal impact on the children
parents and preschool teachers who've
been a part of the program
you've seen that for parents there is
very significant Behavior change parents
who are part of our program are actually
engaging twice the number of time and
number of days as you know counterparts
who are not part of the program they
spend a lot more time with the children
they're a lot more confident in their
abilities and for children themselves we
see that they are actually School ready
and life ready by the age of six if
they've gone through the program their
scores on tests improved by 30 or more
but more importantly they actually shift
to the top one third of you know what
they would have been if they were not
part of the program
even Beyond academic skills I think the
most visible signs of impact are when I
go into the field and talk to parents
and angan body workers right and they
tell me that children are not afraid of
going to school anymore they're not
running away they want to go to the
center they're looking forward to these
playful learning activities as opposed
to running away from them they're
confident in what they can do they don't
mind getting up in front of a group and
showcasing what they are able to do and
they have more self-control and ability
to interact with others as well
I think in that way if you go and see
some of these children you really see
them in a very different trajectory from
you know what they were on otherwise
there have been so many times when I
thought that we've bitter off more than
we can show that we're attempting The
Impossible
and in fact a lot of the ecosystem has
told us this as well that why are you
working with parents how are they going
to make a change how are you using
technology in a country that often
doesn't have any but then luckily it's
always been counterbalanced by the
community of users that we've had who've
told us in no uncertain terms that you
know what you're doing is helpful to us
and we want you to continue working with
us
the most significant part about our
success as the rocket learning
organization has been the fact that
we've been able to get a lot of talented
Mission oriented people right from the
beginning who work together without any
ego all with a single-minded focus to
solve the problem
I've been incredibly fortunate in my
personal journey to have family members
parents my spouse siblings who have been
willing to support whatever I do and in
fact who don't think it's a step down to
go into social entrepreneurship from a
corporate career they think that this is
the best thing that I could be doing and
they're proud of me for doing that and
that takes all pressure on you to follow
your dreams
a lot of my personal Journey has been
driven by folks who have supported me
they've known that I'm not going to be
financially as successful as many of my
peers they've thought that what I'm
doing is the best thing that I could be
doing and that I'll change the world and
that's really been a huge support for me
[Music]